[Musique]
combien de province produisent du vin au
canada quatre provinces ont une
industrie viticole au pays la première
ronde important c'est l'ontario qui avec
6900 hectares cultivés produit entre 60
et 70% du vin canadien
la production est concentrée dans la
péninsule du niagara
c'est la quête élaboré entre autres le
vin de glace 1,20 à la renommée mondiale
dont l'ontario est le principal
producteur sur la planète
la colombie britannique est la seconde
province viticole en importance avec
4000 130 hectares cultivés l'industrie a
connu un essor fulgurant au cours des
dernières années le nombre de vignobles
y est passé de 17 à 929 en un peu plus
de 20 ans la majorité de la production
de vin est concentré dans la vallée de
l'okanagan avec 4 167 hectares de vignes
cultivées le québec vient en troisième
classe
la moitié des 140 vignoble dont beaucoup
demeurent artisanaux sont concentrés en
montérégie
l'industrie a fait adopter l'an dernier
une appellation iger p indication
géographique protégée vins du québec
celle ci assure que tous les raisins
entrant dans la composition des vins
détenant cette certification proviennent
de la province
quant à la nouvelle écosse quatrième
province productrice de vin on y cultive
2 122 hectares de vignes dans une
vingtaine de vignobles l'industrie est
encore jeune mais cette petite région
maritime au climat frais est en train de
faire sa marque grâce à deux spécialités
vin mousseux de méthodes traditionnelles
et un assemblage de blanc baptisé à
dauber ou vins blancs de l'abbé démarrer
une appellation d'origine des vins néo
écossais
[Musique]